[Musique]
j'étais à la caisse du magasin enceinte
de huit mois et là une inconnue est venu
vers moi elle m'a félicité et elle s'est
mise à caresser mon ventre c'était pour
notre premier bébé ma femme souffrait
elle hurlait je l'avais jamais vu comme
ça avant et puis allez tous ces gens
autour d'elle de son vagin le sang les
instruments ça m'a choqué j'ai compté 7
7 dans la salle d'accouchement 7 depuis
j'ai toutes ces images qui tournent en
boucle dans ma tête
quand j'ai dit à ma mère que je voulais
à coucher sans péridurale elle m'a dit
que j'étais folle qu'elle s'était battue
à son époque pour que les femmes
accouchent sans douleur
si j'accouche sans péri je suis plus
féministe
est la lettre notre bébé donc la plupart
du temps je ne sers à rien et quand je
rentre du boulot c'est le pire moment de
la journée l'enfant pleure ya les
coliques les biberons le tire-lait le
bain je me sens complètement impuissant
voilà ses confidences je les recueillent
tous les jours depuis que je suis sage
femme
parce que nous vivons un paradigme des
naissances hyper médicalisé on se permet
de tout commenter tous jugés tout
comparer on va mesurer le vin trop de la
femme on va aller voir à l'intérieur
d'elle-même on va lui demander de
modifier son alimentation son mode de
vie et on sait qui c'est tout le monde
sa famille ses amis ses collègues de
boulot les gynécologues et les
sages-femmes évidemment
et même les inconnus au supermarché
parce que lorsque la femme est enceinte
son corps passe tout simplement dans le
domaine public
alors ça je le savais je l'entendais on
le sait tous
mais quand je les ai vécu moi-même dans
mon corps dans ma tête j'ai pris une
grosse claque et pourtant je vous le
rappelle je suis sage femme et l'hôpital
je connais j'y travaille c'est ma maison
j'y suis en confiance
alors j'étais pas tout à fait à côté de
la plaque avant de devenir enfin
parce que un des grands rôles d'un des
sages femmes c'est de protéger des
intrusions les femmes les bébés et les
partenaires alors moi je leur disais
allez mettez vous dans votre bulle on
vous connaît fait le truc de la bulle
respirer tout ça et tout ça je le
faisais un petit peu comme aujourd'hui
sous les néons dans une grande pièce
froide et toutes les deux heures je
mettais mes doigts dans leur vagin pour
remplir leur dossier
parce que l'hôpital c'est comme un grand
entonnoir on y accueille tout le monde
les grossesses simples comme les
grossesses compliquées
et tout le monde y est traité de la même
manière ou presque que vous attendiez un
petit bébé ou un gros bébé que vous
fassiez un mètre quarante ou 1 mètre 80
votre col de l'utérus doit s'ouvrir d'un
centimètre toutes les deux heures sinon
on intervient médicalement et attention
vous avez une heure pour pousser sinon
ses ventouses ou forceps
en 2021 en suisse c'est un tiers des
femmes qui a accouché par césarienne
l' oms recommande une femme sur dix et
c'est aussi un tiers des femmes à qui on
a provoqué l'accouchement
c'est un peu comme si les femmes elles
savaient plus à coucher par elle même
il y a neuf ans j'étais enceinte de 5
mois j'étais sage femme un salle
d'accouchement et je m'occupais d'une
dame qui était en travail mais elle
avait du mal à dilater alors j'ai dû lui
imposer des choses qu'elle refusait
parce que ça allait complètement contre
son plan de naissance à un moment donné
je suis devenu comme schizophrène
j'étais là à lui parlé de péridurale
d'injection d'ocytocine qu'il fallait
stimuler le travail que c'était pour son
bien et celui de son bébé et en même
temps je me voyais avec mon bébé dans le
ventre dans quelques temps c'est moi qui
serai à sa place
et franchement à sa place j'aurais eu
envie de me barrer
alors à mon retour de congé mat et bien
je suis parti et depuis 7 ans
j'accompagne des couples dans une maison
de naissance
peut-être que vous ne connaissez pas
c'est une maison dans laquelle on
accueille les naissances c'est une
structure à taille humaine bienveillante
comme un cocon
et c'est géré par des sages femmes
souvent c'est très proche d'un hôpital
parce que tout ne se passe pas toujours
comme prévu et on a besoin d'y
transférer une femme ou un bébé
rapidement là bas on offre une prise en
soins adaptés aux grossesses à bas
risque
c'est-à-dire des femmes en bonne santé
et des bébés qui vont bien a priori
et vous savez quoi c'est trop génial
parce que c'est 80 % des grossesses qui
sont normales 80 100 %
et plus le temps passe plus je suis
impressionné par la puissance des femmes
qui enfante
j'ai retrouvé l'aspect sacré de la
naissance ça m'a transformé
pendant les consultations prénatales qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à une heure et demie
on contrôler l'évolution de la grossesse
on finit prise de sang des échographies
mais ça c'est 10 % de la consulte le
reste du temps c'est une discussion avec
la femme avec le couple sur leurs envies
leurs besoins leurs valeurs leurs peurs
sur comment ils sont nés eux mêmes on
détricote le vrai du faux de tout ce
qu'ils ont entendu et on élabore leur
projet de naissance
et ça m'arrive ça m'arrive hyper souvent
de dire mais c'est toi qui ensemble
c'est toi qui va accoucher ce toit qui
sait et toi tu es son partenaire ou sa
partenaire tu la connais mieux que
quiconque tu sais ce dont elle aura
besoin le jour j moi je suis là pour
vous guider avec tout mon expertise et
pour vous partager tout ce que la
science nous a appris jusqu'à maintenant
mais c'est vous les experts
on a créé des protocoles mais ils sont
adaptés aux grosses f à bas risque je
vous le disais et surtout aux
accouchements naturels et je vous en
parle aujourd'hui parce que c'est le
moment où nous les sages femmes on est
complètement autonome un accouchement
par voie basse sans péridurale
alors peut-être que je suis en train de
perdre quelques femmes là dans le public
la péridurale c'est une invention
extraordinaire
ça a libéré les femmes et surtout c'est
une aide médicale qui est très utile en
cas de complications et mon propos ce
n'est pas d'encourager toutes les femmes
à accoucher dans une grange avec un
chaman et son tambour autour d'un grand
feu de joie
quoique ça peut être hyper sympa mais
non mon propos c'est vous dire que vous
avez des droits notamment celui de
bénéficier d'un suivi de grossesse
global une sage femme pour une femme et
vous avez le droit de choisir votre lieu
d'accouchement tout simplement sans
jugement sans vous entendre dire mais
vous êtes inconscient à coucher comme au
moyen-age alors qu'on a le confort de
l'hôpital
les études scientifiques récentes sont
unanimes pour une grossesse normale il
n'y a pas plus de risque d'accoucher en
dehors de l'hôpital que d'accoucher dans
l'hôpital et au contraire c'est moins de
naissances instrumenté moins de
césariennes moins d'hémorragies -
d'épisiotomie et les parents ils nous
disent qu'ils se sentent plus compétents
pour s'occuper de leur bébé
j'en pouvais plus je craquais
complètement
et là elle m'a regardé droit dans les
yeux et elle m'a dit eh oh rappelle-toi
pourquoi tu es là rappelle toi pourquoi
tu veux enfanté naturellement pensé à
toutes les femmes qui l'ont fait avant
toi et qui sont en train de le faire
maintenant et vas-y
et mon bébé est né après quelques
contractions
j'en avais marre j'avais envie de mourir
j'arrêtais pas de dire que toute façon
j'allais pas y arriver et elle m'a tout
simplement pris les mains et elle m'a
dit mais tu y arrives tu le fais
et j'ai accouché comme je le voulais
elle m'avait fait couler un grand bain
d'eau chaude ça m'a tellement soulagée
j'ai même dormi entre les contractions
et comme mon bébé est arrivé c'est mon
copain qui l'a récupéré et moi j'ai fait
naître mon placenta tout seul
depuis je me sens super puissants
ça c'est les nouvelles confidences que
je reçois aujourd'hui
quand on pense que la moitié de la
population mondiale n'a pas accès aux
soins médicaux de base est que malgré
tout ça on est plus de 7 milliards sur
cette terre c'est bien que les femmes
savent enfanté et que les bébés ça venir
au monde non
en parlant de ça peut-être que vous
connaissez le principe de la délivrance
diriger
c'est une injection d'ocytocine de
synthèse un médicament donc qu'on fait à
la naissance de l'enfant pour faciliter
la sortie du placenta la délivrance on
apprend c'est à l'école de sages-femmes
en faculté de médecine et on fait ça
partout où les naissances sont
médicalisés
vous croyez pas qu'une femme qui vient
de mettre au monde un humain de 3 à 4 kg
elle n'est pas capable de sortir un
bifteck de 500 grammes
non le débat par rapport à la délivrance
diriger c'est que si on laisse une femme
se délivrer tout seul mais ça prend du
temps et dans les grandes institutions
on n'a pas ce temps alors nous à
domicile et en maison de naissance on ne
fait pas de schiste cette injection on
la fera uniquement s'il ya des facteurs
de risque de saignement parce que oui l'
oms recommande cette injection à tout le
monde et dans les trois minutes qui
suivent la naissance de l'enfant pour
limiter le risque d'hémorragie du post
partum mais l'om est ce ça donne des
recommandations pour le monde entier et
je vous le rappelle il ya la moitié des
femmes qui n'ont pas de suivi de
grossesse qui sont malnutries et qui
accouchent parfois sans assistance
est-ce que ça ressemble aux conditions
sanitaires de la suisse
michel odent c'est un célèbre
gynécologue français il a passé toute sa
carrière à promouvoir les accouchements
à domicile eh bien il a mis en évidence
que si on laisse tranquille une femme
qui accouche c'est à dire si on ne la
dérange pas si on ne stimule pas son
néocortex sa matière grise elle va
sécréter tout le signe le site aussi
nécessaire pour mettre au monde son bébé
et le placenta qui va avec ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait pas lui demander toutes
les trois minutes alors comment ça va
elle était dure cette contraction vous
avez mal et votre bébé bouge bien et le
liquide amniotique et comment il est
transparent à temps je vais accrocher le
monitoring autour de votre ventre comme
ça on va écouter son coeur et après je
vais vous examinez comme ça on va voir
où on en est
et pour se sentir en confiance sur son
territoire de naissance la femme ne
devrait pas se sentir observé par un ou
une inconnu ou pire 7
elle devrait pas être dans la lumière
elle devrait avoir chaud c'est un peu
comme quand on fait l'amour on n'aurait
pas trop envie de le faire au milieu du
supermarché à coucher c'est un acte
intime et sexuelle
et d'ailleurs c'est la même hormone qui
est en jeu le site hocine
michel odent il dit que la meilleure des
sages femmes c'est celle qui tricotent
au fond de la salle de naissance bon moi
je ne sais pas tricoter et je vous
rassure on en fait un peu plus que ça
mais effectivement la sage femme c'est
cette présence rassurante qui gravitent
autour de la bulle de la femme souvent
dans l'ombre mais qui a toutes les
expertises poursuivre le travail de
l'accouchement et pour gérer les
urgences
mon propos aujourd'hui c'est de vous
dire que vous avez le choix de ne plus
être patient et vous pouvez devenir
actrice et acteur de votre maternité et
de votre paternité autant en profiter on
a de la chance en suisse on peut
accoucher à l'hôpital dans un service
géré par les sages-femmes en clinique et
on peut aussi accoucher en maison
naissance à domicile ou avec votre
propre sage femme qui vient à l'hôpital
il s'appelle une sage-femme à gré
nos voisins les français n'ont pas la
même chanson pour un territoire dix fois
plus grand que le nôtre ils ont
seulement 9 mai en essence alors que
nous on aura plus de 30
et pourtant en 2021 c'est moins de 3 %
des naissances qui ont lieu
en dehors de l'hôpital
alors c'est à nous le professionnel de
santé les pouvoirs publics de soutenir
les structures gérées par les
sages-femmes et d'en faire la publicité
et vous je vous encourage à ne plus être
sage
posez vous des questions faites nous
confiance mais vous avez le droit de pas
être d'accord avec tout ce qu'on vous
dit parce que c'est ensemble qu'on
changera le paradigme des naissances et
parce que prendre soin de la naissance
c'est prendre soin de la société et de
son avenir
[Applaudissements]
ou ou aux eaux